Speaker 1: My audience knows if you've been
following the show for some time that I avoid
being overly optimistic or pessimistic about any
particular election. And I always make clear that
no matter what the polls tell us today, the only
thing we can control is whether we vote. And we
should always vote in that context. In the last
week, there are a bunch of races that are going
very much the wrong direction. There is what
I think can accurately be called a democratic
collapse happening in many races and a possible
red wave rising. Now at the start of the week,
I told you. Zooming out, the forecasts for the
House and Senate have worsened for Democrats and
they have improved for Republicans. But where can
we see this at the individual race level? And I'm
going to tell you up front that these are this is
ugly. These are very ugly numbers that I'm about
to show you here. Look at some of these races.
Florida Senate incumbent Marco Rubio is challenged
by Val Demings. Demings is a great candidate
who had one of the best debate performances
of all the debates that we covered, what at one
point was a Rubio lead in the region of five two,
three, four, five six has now become a seven and
a half point lead for Marco Rubio. Very quickly,
getting out of reach for Val Demings, moving on
to DeSantis versus Charlie Crist. Also in Florida,
Charlie Crist mopping the floor with the Santos
who visibly malfunctioned on Monday night. We
played the clips. We showed you all of
it. What at one point was a five, six,
seven point lead for DeSantis has now swelled
to an 11 point average lead for DeSantis,
with as much as a 14 point lead in some of these
individual polls. This is quickly getting out of
reach Florida quickly looking like it will fall to
the most extreme elements of the Republican Party.
Or stay in their hands, I think better said
in Georgia, again, talking about the best
Democratic performances this cycle. Stacey
Abrams was one of them, facing off against
incumbent Republican Governor Brian Kemp. What
had been as you can see if we go back actually,
I don't I do have the older data. What had been
many polls in the camp plus two, 4 to 5 one area
has now become Kemp six plus 6.7, an almost
seven point lead for Brian Kemp. Not totally
out of reach, but increasingly difficult for
Democratic challenger Stacey Abrams. I don't
tell you this to demoralized, you know, there's
this horrible thing that happens where no matter
what I say about polling, someone's mad. If
I say, look, the polls are looking terrible
for Democrats. People say, oh, David, you're
demoralizing Democrats so they won't go vote.
And if I say, oh, look, the polls are looking
good for Democrats. People write to me, they say,
David, you're giving people false confidence.
They're going to think they don't need to vote.
Folks, I tell you what is going on and I also
tell you how I believe we should react. And no
matter what the polls say, we should react by
voting. But more of these races here is a race
where the Democrat is still winning, but by a
dramatically smaller margin than it was at one
point. Dickson versus Whitmer. Gretchen Whitmer is
the current Democratic governor of Michigan. Tudor
Dixon is the Republican MAGA challenger. If you
look, you see that even as late as August 24th,
Whitmer was up by 16 points by the middle of
September. That was down to an eight point lead.
The lead was halved and now it is a three point
lead for the Democrat, Gretchen Whitmer. Michigan
governorship is now in play for Republicans. It's
sickening. If you look at Ohio, Vance versus Ryan,
Tim Ryan, the Democratic challenger, now
challenger, the Democratic candidate,
J.D. Vance, the Republican candidate, J.D.
Vance. By sucking up ferociously to Donald Trump,
he was able to secure an endorsement from Donald
Trump. If you look at that race, what at one point
was a actually this. This one actually hasn't
changed that much. It's a relevant one to include
because it's important. But it actually has not
changed that much of Vance's plus two. And that's
more or less where it has been, more or less where
it has been. But it is potentially another seat
that will fall to Republicans. Georgia Senate
Walker versus Warnock. Rafael Warnock's lead is
now half a point, and this one is really, really
sickening. Herschel Walker can barely speak and
he can't explain his positions on any issue. He's
completely incoherent. WARNOCK Not a great debate
performance, but clearly the competent candidate.
If you look back at the history here, Warnock was
up 4 to 5 points in late July, still up 4 to 5
points in August. But that lead started to shrink,
shrink, shrink to the point of a tie briefly
during the Walker scandal. Warnock opened up a
five point lead. It's basically a tie. Herschel
Walker, who cannot speak and cannot think,
may replace Raphael Warnock as a senator from
Georgia and then Texas Governor Greg Abbott,
the incumbent, versus Beto O'Rourke. This
at one point was a sort of closer race. If
you look at late June, it was Abbott plus six. If
you look at there was a sort of brief point where
the lead was smaller. I don't remember exactly
where it was. Oh, it was it was actually last
year it was five. This has now become a more than
eight point lead for the incumbent, Greg Abbott,
which in Texas will be quite difficult for a
Democrat to overcome. Doesn't mean we stay home.
What else do you have to do on that day? We should
all vote and we should fight every race. But there
is a serious concern right now that a red wave is
coming. And it's a combination of a few things.
Most importantly, most importantly, this is the
effect of Roe v Wade being overturned, which
helped Democrats fading too soon, being supplanted
by economic concerns. And despite essentially full
employment and almost unanimously positive
economic indicators, rhetoric on inflation,
reigning supreme in the minds of many
voters, and it is shaping up to be
potentially disastrous for Democrats. So what
do we do? We vote. We vote. We vote. We vote.